et merci aujourd'hui d'être là
il est là je remercie encore voilà mais
TF1 voilà et toi aussi parce que tu es
Jean-Luc aussi c'est voilà tu as demandé
et tu es là aujourd'hui je me suis un
peu battu mais je suis très très heureux
parce que j'ai toujours dit que tu étais
d'abord mon ami et tu me défends à
chaque fois et je voulais juste vous
dire bonsoir je vais faire un tout petit
point quand même parce que c'est
important j'ai trouvé Virginie conte
vachement bien pour sa première
non mais c'est vrai parce que quand on a
parlé des animaux elle a dit mais
surtout les cellules là où il est parce
qu'il est beaucoup mieux sans vous
c'était gonflé et j'ai envie de vous
dire bravo et bienvenue dans l'équipe de
TPMP
[Applaudissements]
j'ai des potes Benjamin Castaldi c'était
sur motus son papa voilà il était
derrière moi quand j'étais la voix off
de Motus attiré Beccaro j'en ai fait
1000 émissions il était candidat il est
même été candidats ils ont pas diffusé
l'émission
et puis voilà notre ami pour la vie
évidemment que tu aimes ma chérie à la
folie notre Valérie Bernard c'est un ami
plus que tout Guillaume ça fait 20 fois
qu'il m'invite à la radio j'ai pas pu
Géraldine est né 40 mètres de chez moi à
la clinique de l'Union allée des mûriers
et j'étais juste en dessous impasse du
col du Soulor c'est toi qui l'a fait de
venir au monde
et c'est assez voilà c'est assez
troublant parce que voilà c'est tout
simplement et puis Jean-Marie j'étais à
son mariage et c'est un bonheur Gilles
mais vraiment sincèrement je trouve
qu'il vieillit vachement bien et je
finis puisque c'est la fin de l'émission
avec Daniel
[Musique]
battez pour moi
tu as dit quelque chose tout à l'heure
alors que c'était la pub Cyril j'en
appelle à ta bienveillance en disant ça
fait combien de temps que tu as pas vu
une 3 points de suspension
c'était pendant la pub sache que et on
va faire un tout petit jeu on va faire
un tout petit jeu il y a un lien et elle
ne le sait peut-être même pas qui nous
unit avec Daniel si tu le sais ou si tu
t'en rappelles mais je pense
j'ai rebondi sur ce que tu as dit
surfer
non c'était une d'ailleurs c'était
féminin une zigounette c'était un peu
plus voilà donc alors qu'est-ce qu'elle
est le lien qui nous unit avec Daniel
alors je sais pas mais surtout je n'ai
jamais dit qu'il était mes ex donc je
préviens donc il y a aucun problème
c'est exactement le même lien qu'avec
notre script on est né le même jour le 2
novembre jour de la fête des morts
[Applaudissements]
pas à péchool
numéro 1 Jean-Luc Reichmann et
l'animateur préféré des Français Encore
une fois selon le dernier sondage 5
c'est le nombre de fois il a prêté sa
voix pour les jeux vidéo FIFA 6 le
nombre d'enfants il a reçu une famille
Recon voilà je les connais je les
embrasse tu les connais tous ils
s'embrassent fort j'adore la famille de
Jean-Luc c'est un bonheur et on rigole
hein papa quand on est parti faire du
sport ensemble de la randonnée là
c'était une question de fou on était sur
des vélos électriques en pleine neige
j'en ai monté à 2000 mètres d'altitude
et ensuite
il y avait femme en fond derrière on
tirait tous la langue et l'autre idéal
alors les enfants vous êtes à une autre
et il y a tout le monde qui disait mais
c'est Hanouna avec un chemin qu'est-ce
qui se passe il est l'heure sur lui
comment je suis une bête
non mais j'adore tes nouveaux tatouages
qu'est-ce que c'est que ce binz frère je
suis sur un nouveau délire je prépare
l'été
je t'avais promis c'est sûr
27 ans de télé en tant qu'animateur dont
22 ans sur TF1
7898 quotidiennes d'affilée depuis le
début d'attention la marche le seul
animateur présent 7 jours sur 7 c'est
Jean-Luc 7 jours sur 7 c'est vrai il y
avait les amours avant pendant 5 ans et
demi donc ça fait à peu près 10 000
émissions tu as raison je te le dis et
je le dis à chaque fois ici parce que je
te regarde très souvent et je vous jure
que c'est vrai Jean-Luc il anime
l'émission tous les jours comme si
c'était sa première c'est un truc de fou
je le vois à chaque fois c'est
enthousiasme il est toujours hyper
content d'être là il est à fond t'es
jamais voilà je vois jamais un truc où
je te vois moins bien tu es toujours
hyper content d'être là non mais c'est
vrai mais on a la chance quand même de
faire des métiers extraordinaires je
veux dire on a la chance également
d'être en santé il faut quand même pas
l'oublier et de faire les choses qui
nous plaisent avec des gens qui nous
plaisent et l'énergie que te donne tes
invités ou moi mes candidats au qui que
ce soit ça te booste à 200% quand tu
vois les gens qui viennent de l'île
Maurice de la Guadeloupe qui font des
milliers de kilomètres et qui vous
sourient et qui arrive sur un plateau ou
en disant Léo matéis et extraordinaire
vous battez pour les gosses vous vous
battez pour la bienveillance vous battez
pour la différence ouais j'ai une tâche
sur le nez ouais ma sœur est handicapée
ouais elle est centre au fond et j'en ai
fait mon combat et quand si tu veux pour
aller dans le sens que tu dises sur
ouais j'ai 62 balais je me sens super
bien j'ai pas du tout envie d'arrêter et
à chaque fois c'est comme si c'était la
première et à chaque fois que je vous
vois puisque je vous regarde très
souvent le soir je me dis chouette et
quand il y a une petite comme Virginie
qui fait sa première et qui est solaire
et qui se bat et j'ai vu mon Bernard
comme un fou je sais même pas comment tu
l'auras pas mis un taquet quand sur les
chiens c'était très énervé il était très
énervé je le voyais il ranger son et et
elle seule a dit laissez-les où il est
parce que le chien il est mieux sans
vous j'ai dit cette fille elle
est gonflée et là tu t'es libre Bernard
Montiel 30 ans de télé il a pas su le
dire et elle
après 30 ans de télé quel serpent
exactement alors que elle était super
bien c'est super mimi je voudrais dire
que Léo c'est la fiction la plus forte
de TF1 en audience 4 millions 2 je vous
le dis à HPI et Léo Mattei mais voilà et
c'est vrai que c'est un truc de de
dingue sa cartonné la nouvelle saison
plus de 4 millions à chaque fois ouais
je suis assez ému parce que tu sais
comment ça se passe quand on te met dans
un autre contexte là c'était un flic
pour défendre les enfants pour défendre
la différence et il est vrai que sur
avec les replay on a fait 5 millions de
téléspectateurs c'est c'est demain soir
c'est pas ce soir c'est non mais il y a
pas il y a aucun problème mais qu'il
aurait cru quoi moi arrivant le mec de
TF1 que tout le monde connaît faisant
comme dirait Jean-Marie tagazat tagazou
arrivée à défendre à ce moment-là à ce
moment-là et arriver à défendre les
gosses et cette de différence
tous ces toutes l'équipe là Stomy Bugsy
tu le connais très très bien il a il a
eu quelques délicatesses avec la police
je l'ai mis commissaire bien sûr lola a
été harcelé pendant toute sa jeunesse
pour grossophobie et je l'ai mis avec
moi voilà le gamin qui est là Alexandra
Adam il a grandi dans un foyer toute sa
vie
quand il était gamin et donc tout ça les
gens le savent pas mais toi tu le sais
parce que toi aussi tu prônes aussi la
différence et on est là et quand tu dis
qu'une série comme tu es comme Léo
Mathis sur TF1 c'est exporte dans le
monde entier et ben tu dis tu es fier de
bravo à Nathalie aux équipes
Nathalie qu'on embrasse aussi et c'est
vrai que ça cartonne depuis le lancement
disons les scores sont toujours aussi
incroyables et puis c'est vrai que Léo
Mattéi moi je sais que Jean-Luc c'est
c'est ton kiffany alors attention la
marche mais c'est que c'est ton kiffe
absolu quand même alors c'est plus
attention à Marge depuis 10 ans c'est
les douze coups de midi mais il y a un
décalage
horaire je regardais
tu vois il a toujours le soleil en lui
son anniversaire aujourd'hui d'ailleurs
oh c'est vrai
et 60
Jean-Luc
c'est vrai que tu avais écrit un livre
moi quand j'avais vu le titre de ton
livre non mais c'était je me suis dit
mais c'est pas possible il va quand même
parce que tu étais venu même nous voir
pour si tu parlais de ta tâche et
à quel moment tu t'es dit ça y est je
m'en fous la tâche la merde ce qu'au
début tu l'as tu l'as caché beaucoup
mais disons que c'est pas un jeu bien
sûr on me la faisait cacher
moi au bout d'un moment au bout de six
mois un an je me reconnaissais pas je
suis allé voir Yves Bigot à l'époque en
disant tu sais je me sens pas bien avec
ce maquillage et comme je le dis au
début je me que tu es mon doigt et je
faisais ça sur la tâche parce qu'à
chaque fois on vous met un petit coup de
poudre un petit truc en plus parce que
il y a une différence je te rappelle que
à l'époque c'était à l'époque de de
cette année Jean-Luc Delarue que
j'adorais et c'était le genre idéal la
chemise blanche le petit truc aucun
problème il était séducteur et puis de
l'autre côté on avait Christophe
Christophe Dechavanne qui était le
trublion et tout était possible et d'un
seul coup où se placer au milieu de tout
ça je me sentais mal sur ma page je
sentais pas bien et je me disais que
chacun de nous d'entre nous avait vécu
quelque chose à l'école il y avait le
petit il y avait le juif il y avait le
gâteau il y avait le gros il y avait le
maigre il y avait une tache de rousseur
il y avait le rouquin il y avait le
maghrébin il y avait le black qui avait
tout ça et moi j'étais la tâche
et comme on le fait sur les homati ou
dans cette quotidienne des douze coups
de midi on met en avant la différence et
je me suis dit que mais j'étais pas tout
seul que chacun avait sa blessure chacun
avait connu un enfant dans la cour de
récréation on m'appelait nérapé on me
disait mais dis-moi un peu ta mère quand
elle était enceinte elle avait envie de
fraise pour avoir ça sur la tête et j'ai
une petite amie à l'époque c'était une
copine qui m'a dit c'était un passe du
col du Soulor voilà pas juste à côté de
la clinique de l'Union et qui m'a dit je
me rappelle très très bien de son prénom
mais je le dirai pas mais c'était mais
on peut pas sortir ensemble tu as vu ce
que tu as sur le nez
quand tu as 14 ans et que ton prof de
français te dit à l'école Saint Joseph
la tâche au tableau devant 32 élèves à
partir de ce moment-là je suis allé voir
il Bigot qui est devenu mon pote bien
évidemment et je lui dis tu sais et on
était en 97 sur France 2 c'est le patron
1997 et je lui dis tu sais je me
ressemble pas et quand aujourd'hui il y
a des mecs comme Slimane qui me dit mais
moi aussi on me montrait du doigt sur ma
différence et tu nous a donné de la
force Slimane il était gamin quand
j'étais au début à l'école et il a vu
apparaître il m'a dit j'ai vu apparaître
ta tâche progressivement à l'antenne il
t'a dit quoi il t'a dit vas-y fais comme
tu le sens si tu te sens mieux comme ça
vas-y
il m'a dit ouais tu comprends tu as des
pompes jaunes avec je dis si c'est une
question de couleur j'arrête les pompes
jaune et je laisse la tâche et et
j'avais ses cheveux sur jaune pour un
petit clin d'oreille évidemment un
Coluche alors justement tu as commencé
la télé en étant voix off pour des
séries des bandes-annonces et pour les
jeux de Nagui regardez
[Applaudissements]
Colombo confronté au Mystère de la
chambre forte lundi 22h30 sur TF1 radio
rouge à l'orange sanguine il est méchant
parce que qui va hériter de la maison et
des biens de Yann du Pérou Stéphane
Jacquet prétend qu'il ait son fils
illégitime et le seul héritier légal
mais
[Musique]
non je pars débutants
alors la première fois qu'on te voit à
la télé c'est pas en tant qu'animateur
en tant comédien c'est dans la série
tribunal en 90 et j'ai qu'une chose à
dire startup un peu con regardez
Benoît Louvain un ancien artiste de
cirque a recueilli et élever une
tigresse Lola celle-ci est maintenant
adulte cité au tribunal correctionnel
pour détention sans autorisation d'une
espèce non domestiquée Benoît était en
cavale depuis un an lorsqu'il a été
appréhendé lors d'un banal control
routier je travaillais à droite à gauche
les vendanges en septembre les chantiers
l'hiver le ramassage des fruits l'été
mais tout ça c'était avant avant quoi
Monsieur Louvain
avant l'accident qui a eu avec une
petite gamine
ses parents portaient plainte et j'ai dû
partir
c'est magnifique ça y est c'est
magnifique tu te rappelles de ta
première dans les amours
vous avez oui ça vient drôle de look non
j'étais un peu plus mince peut-être mais
oui regarde tu vois à peine
tu vois là j'ai pas la tâche parce
qu'ils me l'ont fait il faisait
maquiller bien sûr et j'étais pas du
tout d'accord avec le producteur de
l'époque que je salue bien bas et c'est
bien
avec sa femme bien sûr en disant mais
vous pouvez pas garder ça il faut il
faut ressembler au gendre idéal il faut
séduire là à l'époque on ne parlait pas
de ménagère vulgairement ce mot mais
c'était à l'époque c'était les cibles
commerciales ne peuvent pas accepter
quelqu'un qui soit différent et là là je
souffrais mais bon je voilà ça a duré un
an ça a duré oui à peu près un an et
après voilà ça a été un petit peu
compliqué et mais voilà je m'assume
totalement et je me sens beaucoup mieux
comme ça
écoute tu es très bien avec tes
tatouages aussi
c'est vrai que je suis assez beau gosse
[Musique]
bonjour bonjour à tous bonjour à tous je
suis Jean-Luc si l'amour a toujours
guidé votre vie chérir et votre
principal préoccupation dans la vie et
bien restez bien qu'elle est dans votre
fauteuil et regardez les amours
cependant une demi-heure nous allons
essayer de s'amuser de rire est-ce que
vous êtes d'accord mes amours du jour
oui vous êtes d'accord et bien écoutez
ça tombe très très bien enchanté je
m'appelle Jean-Luc et vous même bonjour
c'est Patricia
la première c'est la première impasse
aujourd'hui quand tu fais ton jeu de ce
que dit tu es pareil ça veut dire mais
c'est à dire que tu es tout en direct
c'est ta première
et c'était le costume de mon père parce
qu'il y avait pas d'argent à l'époque
hein
mais c'est ça c'est c'est ce bonheur de
partager mais tu sais c'est c'est
sincèrement le partage vous vous êtes
ici chacun est et effectivement à ses
intérêts et ses envies c'est Étienne
moujon qui m'avait dit il faut faire
l'équilibre entre ses intérêts et ses
envies et et moi mon envie c'était de
rassembler c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui
c'est délicat de rassembler toi voilà il
y a un microcosme de la société qui
regarde Hanouna il y en a un autre qui
regarde Yann Barthès et et et chacun sa
petite cellule aujourd'hui sur TF1 on
essaie d'être le plus rassembleur
possible ce qui est super compliqué et
et en 95 ou 94 j'avais déjà cette envie
de rassembler à tous les étages nos
enfants ils ont leur jeux vidéo isolant
tout tout leur écran leur voilà leur
Netflix et autres mais qui peut se
targuer d'être rassembleur toi tu es
rassembleurs parce que tu as envie
d'aller de cette à 77 ans moi j'ai
regardé mais j'étais un peu plus simple
ouais mais j'étais épaté par la moyenne
d'âge qui te regarde on pensait que
c'était des super jeunes et ben ils sont
pas super jeunes donc il faut faire
attention aux plus jeunes pour essayer
de montrer l'exemple et puis essayer de
garder le socle de personnes plus âgées
qui nous regardent et voilà ce côté
rassembleur il devient un peu délicat
maintenant en août dernier moi Jean-Luc
j'ai été j'étais très touché par ton
texte
parce que sur insta tu as rendu hommage
à ta maman qui était ta plus fidèle
téléspectrice Josette et c'est vrai que
ton mot sur sur insta était formidable
tu as mis un mot qui a mis aujourd'hui
je pleure mon cœur ne brille plus le
tien s'est éteint ce soir ta place sera
vide à la belote car tu es parti rejouer
papa une drôle de vie tu mettais tous
les jours du soleil dans ma vie maman
avec tes mots si juste tes expressions
si drôle tes réflexions si des
harcèdentes a été fier de toi
non mais c'est pire que ça tu sais toi
tu as une bande
vous êtes là vous rigolez vous donnez
vos avis vous êtes hyper complémentaire
quand tu es animateur face à une caméra
tu regardes un trou noir tu parles pour
qui moi je parlais pour ma mère avant 28
ans j'ai un peu les recettes excusez-moi
et pendant 28 ans je disais bonjour à
maman
en disant bonjour à tous Bienvenue c'est
le soleil et c'était le soleil de maman
et un jour
quand tu fais ta rentrée fin août tu dis
bonjour il est midi
le soleil brille moi le soleil brille
mais alors d'un seul coup tu as un voile
il a fallu que je respire comme il faut
que je respire là parce que je
m'attendais pas à ce qu'on parle de
maman mais c'est une femme qui nous a
toujours inculqué le positivisme à
l'extrême tu sais quand tu arrives et
que c'était une femme brillante mon père
également et que tu as un enfant
handicapé qui rentre dans ta vie donc ma
sœur qui est né effectivement c'est toi
qui a remarqué hein
c'est moi qui l'ai remarqué mais c'est
elle aussi c'est à dire que comment
transformer le négatif en positif ma
petite sœur est sourde donc à un moment
il faut que je trouve le mot juste et je
m'aperçois qu'il y a un problème et que
l'intonation l'articulation va faire que
elle va me comprendre mieux donc
effectivement j'ai découvert son
handicap et c'est pour ça que quand il y
avait Michel Cottin j'ai demandé à ce
que tous les programmes soient
sous-titrés quelle première animateur a
exigé ton ton contrat de sous-titrer tes
émissions mais évidemment c'était pour
ma sœur la première fois que j'arrive à
Toulouse
à l'Union j'arrive je dis à ma sœur
c'était la première fois Noël je lui dis
ça va ça te plaît ce que je fais à la
télé
en bas
je m'aperçois que à l'époque il y avait
que les journaux télévisés puisque
c'était Antiope qui sous-titrait pour
les gens et c'était les infos et il y
avait la non accessibilité à toutes les
personnes sourdes ou malentendantes il
faut juste que tu saches Cyril à
aujourd'hui il y a 5 millions de
personnes qui sont malentendantes ou
sourdes nos parents nos grands-parents
nous on commence à être
sourde et du coup en fait effectivement
ça a été un gros problème pour elle
parce qu'elle ne pouvait pas regarder la
télé on avait le décodeur Antiope
exactement
et j'avais demandé à ce que Canal
sous-titre aussi les films français et
canal avait répondu et moi je suis
maintenant je me suis battu moi pour
tout ce qui était les flux les jeux les
divertissements et grâce voilà aussi à
toutes les personnes qui qui ont été à
mes côtés dans ce dans son vrai combat
je je suis très heureux parce que ma
petite sœur a fait waouh c'est chouette
et elle pouvait et c'était fantastique
et sur la différence je me suis abattu
pour avoir le premier couple homosexuel
sur le canapé des amants cette
différence là la première fois quand je
dis à Madame Cottin qui était tu vois ma
responsable la grande toile de France
Télévision je me suis dit mais on va
inviter un couple homosexuel pardon on
va faire des émissions spéciales
homosexuelles j'ai dit jamais j'ai dit
ça Michel vous vous rendez pas compte
ils disent non il va y avoir des couples
homosexuels tout comme il y a des
couples bi des couples hétéros il y a
des groupes mais je vous parle de ça on
est en 97 je sais pas si tu te rends
compte et d'un seul coup ils me prennent
pour un fou et aujourd'hui quelle joie
de voir qui a il y a des il y a des gens
de tous horizons de tout univers de
toutes les couleurs de toutes les
religions qui sont là mais quel bonheur
est de toutes ces différences donc
effectivement maman du côté négatif
toujours elle en faisait un côté positif
et moi ma petite sœur qui était sourde
et ben aujourd'hui je suis heureux parce
que elle est totalement insérée dans la
société et parce que c'est 5 millions de
personnes qui sont soit déficientes
auditives soit malentendante ou les deux
millions de malvoyants ou non voyants il
y a 2 millions de nos voyants malvoyants
en France par rapport à
l'autodestruction et ben ils peuvent
nous suivre et vous suivre ensemble
alors justement ta soeur elle était très
reconnaissante de ce qu'elle a fait pour
aller à la témoigner dans un
documentaire qui était consacré regardez
[Musique]
pour être ouvert pour travailler comment
on parle il fait la musique avec tous
les amis trop peu guitare
[Musique]
comment on rigole
il me rend joyeux il me donne la force
[Applaudissements]
je voulais dire je voudrais dire un truc
c'est que j'ai très peu de d'amis dans
le dans le métier c'est vrai que
Jean-Luc il fait vraiment partie de de
mes amis et c'est vraiment un mec sur
qui je peux compter à chaque fois que je
l'appelle à chaque fois il est il est là
et voilà je je on rêvé de faire des
choses ensemble ça arrivera peut-être un
jour dans une autre vie moi Jean-Luc
Jean-Luc t'as pratiqué le karaté toi
très haut niveau ouais mais Benjamin
Castaldi aussi je l'ai vu cette semaine
se défoncer
et je dois t'avouer que c'était de plus
en plus épais et je le sentais tu méfier
de plus en plus mais il était toujours
cher tu vois ce que tu as arrêté tu as
fait un accident de moto
mais bon j'ai voilà je suis en kit de
sous complètement
mais en même temps ça m'a donné une
force mentale insupportable je pense
puisque on parle d'enfant moi à chaque
fois je peux parler d'enfants puisque le
c'est le monde de demain les enfants il
faut que les enfants ils aillent faire
du sport il faut qu'ils aillent
s'exprimer il faut qu'ils aillent sur
les stades il faut qu'ils aillent dans
les gymnase que ce soit du sport de
combat comme comme j'ai fait ou alors au
théâtre il faut qu'il puisse partager et
puis s'exprimer devant un public pour
savoir où ils en sont dans leur vie et
et pouvoir se comparer aussi tu vois ce
que je veux dire donc il faut sortir de
tout ça alors moi je voulais dire tu
parlais des enfants Jean-Luc et moi je
voudrais te remercier ce soir parce que
grâce à toi une grande star de
télévision est né puisque sa première
télé il a fait être chez toi il était
venu avec sa maman en 2005 il faisait la
même taille qu'aujourd'hui c'est Sacha
et le base qui était sur ton plateau
regardez
Sacha
[Applaudissements]
comment
[Musique]
déjà ce que j'aime pas la cantine à la
maison les épinards les épinards on est
d'accord avec
moi je vais vous
raconter ce n'est pas évident
et il y avait une fille
[Musique]
et alors comment ça s'est terminé cette
histoire
[Applaudissements]
de ma vie je suis à la recherche donc